el concepto del equilibrio de nash es un
concepto tan importante que yo considero
que merece su vídeo propio y es posible
que ustedes reconozcan este apellido nas
del nombre john nash que fue
representado por rosa chrome en la
película una mente brillante y ese es un
concepto de la teoría de juegos aunque
teoría de juegos puede sonar muy
sofisticado pero en realidad trata
acerca de juegos aquí tenemos un ejemplo
parecido al dilema de los prisioneros
que se vio en el vídeo anterior en donde
esto realmente es un juego tenemos
diferentes jugadores y diferentes
estrategias y con base en las
estrategias de interacción entre ellos
se puede terminar en diferentes estados
y por lo tanto tener diferentes
resultados aquí está la traducción de la
definición del equilibrio de nash con
base en el sitio web de princeton que es
una buena fuente ya que ahí
jonas pasó varios años de su vida
profesional trabajando
ordenas teoría de juegos es un estado
estable de un sistema que involucra
varios participantes interactivos en el
dilema de los prisioneros tenemos a dos
participantes a este y a este en el cual
ningún ningún participante puede ganar
por un cambio de estrategia en tanto que
todos los demás participantes
permanezcan sin cambios
permanezcan sin cambios consideremos los
diferentes estados en este sistema de
acá y veamos si alguno de éstos coincide
con este criterio vamos a nombrar los
estados éste es el estado 1 éste es el
estado 2 éste es el estado 3 y este es
el estado 4 si nosotros nos encontramos
en el estado 1 alguno de esos
participantes podría ganar si cambiará
su estrategia suponiendo que el otro
participante no tiene cambios si estamos
aquí en el estado 1 vemos que arturo
está negando lo y benito también está
negando su crimen
bueno aquí arturo podría mejorar su
situación si cambiara su estrategia si
pasara de ese escenario de negación
hacia la confesión así que arturo puede
cambiar su estrategia
y ganas siempre y cuando supongamos que
benito permanece en la negación también
podemos ver lo contrario si arturo
permanece sin cambios y benito confiesa
pasa de este estado a éste benito va a
mejorar pues de dos años va a pasar a un
año y por estas razones en cualquiera de
estos dos casos aquí no tendríamos un
equilibrio de nash este es éste no es un
equilibrio de nash
aquí vimos dos ejemplos en lo que el
jugador puede ganar siempre y cuando el
otro participante permanezca sin cambios
que es lo contrario aquí ningún
participante puede ganar si es que los
demás participantes permanecen sin
cambios este es el ejemplo en donde
benito permanece en la negación y arturo
cambia su estrategia y confiesa este
segundo ejemplo es donde arturo
permanece en la negación y benito cambia
su estrategia y confiesa ahora veamos el
escenario número 2 estamos aquí y vamos
a ver qué pasa en este
estar aquí arturo que ha confesado tiene
un año de cárcel podría él mejorar esta
sentencia si cambia su estrategia pues
no si él niega y benito permanece
constante pues aquí le aumentará en los
años en lugar de un año va a tener dos
años así que no le conviene así que
arturo no puede cambiar su estrategia
aquí ahora veamos qué pasa con benito
aquí suponiendo que arturo permanece
constante que pasa con benito puede
mejorar el cambiando su estrategia
bueno vemos que aquí él tiene 10 años
pues sí si él pasa de negar a confesar
va a pasar de 10 años a 3 años y si si
le convendría y este es otro ejemplo en
donde un participante puede ganar
siempre y cuando el otro participante
permanezca constante basta con que uno
de los jugadores pueda ganar cuando los
demás permanecen sin cambios para que no
estemos en un equilibrio de nash así que
el que benito pueda mejorar su situación
siempre y cuando arturo permanezca sin
cambios
no es un equilibrio de las aquí tampoco
es más
ahora veamos el estado 3 en este estado
tenemos que benito confiesa y arturo
niega estamos aquí analicemos el punto
de vista de arturo suponiendo que benito
no cambia su estrategia podrá mejorar
arturo pues sí puede pasar de la
negación que está en este estado hacia
la confesión y su sentencia se reduciría
de diez años a tres años así que si
benito no cambia él puede cambiar su
estrategia y mejoras y esto por sí
solito es evidencia de que aquí no hay
un equilibrio de nash así que en el
estado 3 tampoco hay equilibrio de nash
más
esto es simétrico no tenemos que
considerar las opciones de benito con el
simple hecho de que arturo pueda pasar
de aquí a acá mientras benito permanece
constante indica que aquí no hay un
equilibrio de nash y ahora veamos el
último escenario y si ustedes vieron el
vídeo anterior ya sabrán qué es lo que
ocurre aquí aunque aquí lo veremos con
un poquito más de detalle en este estado
4 tenemos que ambos confesar veamos qué
sucede desde el punto de vista de arturo
y tendremos a benito constante entonces
estamos aquí si estamos aquí en esta
columna donde benito no cambia su
concesión podrá mejorar
arturo su sentencia si cambia de
estrategia pues no aquí vemos que él ya
tiene tres años pero si lo niega
mientras benito sigue confesando lo
entonces va a aumentar a diez años lo
que no creo que le guste mucho así que
aquí arturo no puede cambiar mientras
benito quede constante ahora quedamos en
el punto de vista de benito nos
encontramos aquí en donde arturo no
cambia su estrategia se queda aquí
confiesa y benito podrá mejorar su
sentencia si pasa de la concesión a la
negación pues no porque mientras arturo
se quede constante estos tres años que
ya tenía asignados le aumentarían a diez
años lo que no le conviene entonces aquí
benito no puede mejorar si es que arturo
no cambia también su estrategia así que
hemos encontrado en este estado 4 en
donde ningún participante puede ganar
por un cambio de estrategia en tanto que
los demás participantes permanezcan sin
cambios así que esta parte es importante
aquí no podemos movernos en diagonal de
manera que tanto benito como arturo
cambien su estrategia simultáneamente
así que ningún participante puede ganar
en tanto que todos los demás
participantes permanezcan sin cambios
aquí si tenemos un equilibrio de nash
aquí si hay un equilibrio
y equilibrio de nash
así que este es un estado estable